[موسيقى]
19 سنه بقولها لك
وما فيش حاجه بتهون
وانا عملت ايه غلط في حياتي
بالاحرمني من الاتنين
مرحبا ارقام كبيره من ناحيه المشاهدات
يحققها جعفر العمده لاسباب عديده ابرزها
جماهيريه محمد رمضان ومحمد سامي واشتياق
الجمهور لهما معا بالاضافه لوقت العرض
المناسب جدا لكن ورغم هذه الارقام هناك
اتهامات مستمره بالمبالغه والسؤال كيف
ولماذا انا شايف انه السنه دي محمد رمضان
محمد سامي المخرج مركزين جدا ان هم يعملوا
نجاح شعبي وشعبوي كبير جدا اكتر من ان هم
حتى
دخلوا عناصر فنيه كتير في المسلسل
بيغازلوا طبقات شعبيه كتير وبيحاولوا ان
هم يثبتوا للشارع ان المسلسل طول الوقت
موجود المنطقه ايضا كانت سببا في
الانتقادات اللي طالت العمل فالسيده زينب
في المسلسل ليست هي سيده زينب في الواقع
وهناك جمهور يؤكد بانه لو محمد سامي كلف
نفسه وزاره المنطقه ولو لمره واحده لكان
كتب العمل بشكل مختلف تماما المسلسل قادر
ان هو يكذب يعني فئات كبيره من الجمهور في
بالتاكيد ملاحظات يعني كتير على البناء
الدرامي على طريقه اداء محمد رمضان لشخصيه
جعفر العمده اللي هو حد اكبر منه في العمر
بحوالي 20 سنه في على الورق لكن على
المستوى الجاذبيه الشعبيه المسلسل محقق
نجاح كبير
دي جمله بزياره منطقه السيده زينب وسؤال
اهاليها عن رايهم بالعمل وبالمنطقه بحسب
رؤيه محمد تامين هو عامل
انما السيده زينب دي منطقه الكبش والسيده
زينب والمدبح وزينب عابدين والدوران
والسيده دي كلها ملهاش كبير كل واحد له
واحد في كبير مش كبير بقى واحد محترم في
منطقته هو اللي بيحل المشاكل والناس انما
واحد فرضاني للسيده زينب عمر السيده زينب
ابدا ولا التصوير ده خالص في السيده زينب
يعني صلاح السعدني ربنا يدي له الصحه كان
زمان عمل مسلسل برضو هنا اهو جابوا
التصوير كله هنا في السيده كان بيصور في
جميع السيده والتصوير وكله جاب جامع
السيده انما ده ما جابش اي حاجه في السيده
خالص دي معموله غير السيره زينب خالص
المنطقه دي انا من السيده زينب بقى لي 25
سنه هنا عمره كله ما شفتش العموديه دي
خالص ولا العرف اللي هو بيتكلم عليه كل
واحد في حاله دلوقتي
انما زمن كان فيه الاعداد وصلح وبتاع
ويجيبوا الناس ويقعدوا معاهم وكده انما
دلوقتي ما فيش زفوني
[موسيقى]
بالنار
دي متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات